qu'on se le dise il y à des chefs qui
cartonne en cuisine d'authie cartonne à
la télé et ce qui cartonne tout court
c'est le cas de philippe etchebest qui
avec son caractère bien trempé et sont
habillées impeccable a réussi à se faire
une place de choix dans le salon des
français face à la tête de l'émission
cauchemar en cuisine de retour depuis
hier soir sur m6 le chef a une fois
encore fait sensation pour ce premier
épisode de la saison 11 3,1 millions de
personnes se sont donné rendez-vous en
cuisine pour suivre les rebondissements
des aventures des tubes est et ses
acolytes une nouvelle formule nous on a
pu retrouver un ancien héros de top chef
malaurie qui est venu prêter main forte
à philippe etchebest paul henri chollet
laisse ça marchait je compte sur toi
pourrez compter sur moi à chaque coup de
gueule du chef les médias s'affolent et
les téléspectateurs en redemandent
alors avez vous aimé la nouvelle formule
de cauchemar en cuisine moi j'adore je
déteste la cuisine à la télévision
c'est le seul qui décorait spécialités
culinaires vous alors je fais je fais
très bien je fais très bien les oeufs
brouillés
non c'est vrai oui c'est très dur les
yeux il est excellent mais il est
concernant c'est très intéressant et
franchement avec lui on voit émission de
télévision effectivement il ya un peu de
cuisine alors il aurait 5 a pas aimé
c'est nicolas perso j'ai pas été là la
deuxième version avec mallorie c'est
vrai les gens adorent et nico les gens
ont adoré le droit de ne pas aimer je
peux dire allez tous bien cherché baisse
et qui bouscule les gens qui se passe un
vrai truc qui est une mécanique qui
fonctionne très bien
les mallory j'ai senti ultra gêner ses
terres qu'il était gentil il est gentil
de nature mais bon il avait un peu de
mal
il avait quand même un peu de mal à
bousculer les lieux c'est ce petit
changement voilà on a le style malaurie
qui est donc devenu l'acolyte de
philippe etchebest dans la nation faut
garder je passe le relais à mallory
c'est exactement la personne dont jean
jacques et johan ont besoin il pourra
donc parfaitement me seconde et dans ma
mission
là le challenge pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est que jean-jacques y retrouve sa
passion qu'il a perdu en fait et en
retrouvant cette passion ab il va
avancer
on va faire une chouette recettes
ensemble et qu'on va mettre à la carte
de son restaurant
ça me convient
j'ai hâte de retrouver jouannet jean
jacques et de là vous montrer les
restaurants mais en tout cas le chef
jesse à une free ça passe aux journées
je me suis permis de prendre sa place h
f ça m'a bien non ça va très bien ouais
quand un peu les sourcils
en tout cas il a bien assuré il a
parfaitement rempli sa mission
voilà il est là pour l'aider contractée
au contraire pour montrer que même quand
on a eu des épreuves on peut y arriver
donc il est parfaitement dans son rôle
est en revanche etchebest qui est
formidable c'est qu'ils ont senti au
départ le potentiel de ce mec passe
quand même c'est un pur il a mis
plusieurs années à imposer auprès du
public premier objectif top tchèque ça
fait plus de deux millions cinq cent
mille alors ça me faisait un million de
moins il ya trois cas lancera fait 3
millions 103 millions c'est la crise ma
rancune dans la moyenne avec les jours
l'année dernière et 2 millions 3 c'est
ça hier trois millions sont donc vous
appelle semaine prochaine c'est marrant
parce qu'être baisse avec son personnage
de méchant on pourrait le détestais ça
m'a un peu laurence boccolini qui était
très méchant dans maillon faible est à
l'époque les gens la détester et lui ont
l'adorent pourquoi parce que le format
de l'émission 100 sincère oui oui ma
démission il est mortelle il ya tout il
ya de la famille de l'émotion il ya des
tensions il ya la cuisine franchement
génération des meilleurs cuisiniers
choper vous cuisinez oui je cuisine très
bien fait quoi touta italien tout ce que
vous voulez pour l'élection frais
plusieurs faits tout sophie tunisien
éventuellement je prouverai des bullets
il va très bien bas dans les bric et
broc c'est beau chez madame avril au
niveau de l'émission mais comment tout à
fait d'accord avec toi mais c'est
effectivement il a hélas le personnage
un peu de battre cote mais à la fois il
est hyper paternaliste il est votre
empathie
il ya quelque chose d'ultra sens archers
lui c'est un type qui a fait du rugby
sas en est là les valeurs est des
rugbymans voilà c'était son qu'il est
toujours dans la mêlée
on lâche rien et en même temps on se
serre les coudes moi j'adore ces dessins
sinon c'est mon héros bonsoir fillon
robert et langue de boeuf méplat ne
revient plus en fait c'est vers ces gens
à aller sur mars compensée
téléspectateurs tient de cauchemar en
cuisine
oui à 67 % et non à 33 % c'est rare que
ce soit aussi toucher un gros gros
succès hier